te presento una serie aquí 3x cuadrada
menos 3x a las 5 más 13 x a la 8 menos
3x a la 11 y así sucesivamente y lo que
quiero que hagas en este vídeo es hacer
una pausa primero que nada y ver si
puedes expresar esta serie como una
serie geométrica es decir que es la suma
de potencias de cierto número y de poder
hacerlo ver cuál es el intervalo de
convergencia porque por supuesto esta es
una función que depende de x muy bien
entonces suponiendo que ya hiciste una
pausa ya lo pensaste al menos vamos a
primero factorizar todo lo que podamos
factorizar de esta serie entonces esto
de aquí será exactamente igual a 3x
cuadrada que multiplica a quien bueno
primero tendríamos que multiplicar por 1
para que nos dé 3 x cuadrada luego menos
porque tenemos el signo menos ya factor
izamos el 3 y necesitamos multiplicar
por x al cubo para obtener x a la 5
verdad
ahora bien aquí sigue el más y ya factor
izamos el 3 y ahora necesitamos
multiplicar por equis a las 6 para que
por este x cuadrada nos dé x a la 8 x a
las 6 menos ya factor izamos el 3 y
habrá hay que multiplicar por x a la 9 y
así sucesivamente verdad cerremos este
paréntesis y ya que tenemos esto ahora
podríamos identificar cada uno de estos
términos como potencias de x al cubo
verdad por ejemplo tenemos aquí bueno
aquí el 3x cuadrada sigue y el 1
podríamos pensar que es x al cubo
elevada a la potencia 0 verdad y aquí
luego bueno aquí sigue el menos x al
cubo elevado a la primer potencia
x al cubo elevado al cuadrado menos x al
cubo elevado al cubo y así sucesivamente
muy bien entonces de hecho aquí ya se ve
muy bien cómo es nuestra serie
geométrica verdad ya se ve muy bien
quién es nuestra nuestra proporción
común excepto que todavía no sabemos
bien qué pasa con los signos pero esto
es muy fácil porque si copiamos todo
exactamente igual aquí podríamos ver que
por ejemplo tenemos un signo menos cada
vez que tenemos las potencias impares y
un signo más cada vez que tenemos las
potencias pares y eso ya lo hemos visto
en varios vídeos porque podríamos por
ejemplo pensar en menos x al cubo
elevado a la 0 + menos x al cubo elevado
a la 1 verdad y aquí menos 1 elevado a
la 1 es menos 1 lo cual nos da estén
menos y x al cubo elevado a la 1 es lo
que teníamos acá arriba podemos sumar
sumar perdón menos x al cubo al cuadrado
y por supuesto como tenemos un signo
menos elevado al cuadrado nos da así no
más
y luego podríamos concluir con más menos
x al cubo elevado al cubo muy bien y
esto otra vez se da porque menos 1 al
cubo es menos 1 lo cual nos da el signo
menos muy bien entonces aquí ya tenemos
nuestra serie geométrica simplemente x
3x cuadrada la pregunta es bueno cuando
esta serie geométrica converge y de
hecho sabemos que las series geométricas
convergen siempre que la proporción
común o la razón común sea el bueno su
valor absoluto sea menor que 1 es decir
convergen
y la proporción común que en nuestro
caso es menos x al cubo si el valor
absoluto de menos x al cubo es menor que
esto que nos está diciendo el valor
absoluto de menos x al cubo en realidad
es el valor absoluto de x al cubo verdad
simplemente el valor absoluto de un
número es el mismo valor absoluto que el
de su negativo verdad ambos son de hecho
no negativos ahora bien tenemos el valor
absoluto menor que 1 entonces tendremos
menos 1 menor que x al cubo menor que 1
y si sacamos raíz cúbica en cada uno de
estos lados tendremos menos 1 menor que
x menor que 1 y este es nuestro
intervalo de convergencia
este es el intervalo de convergencia el
intervalo de convergencia es el
intervalo menos 1
el intervalo de convergencia es el
intervalo menos 11 sin incluir el menos
1 y el 1 muy bien entonces lo que
obtuvimos es lo siguiente esto será
igual a de hecho podríamos saber muy
bien en el intervalo de convergencia
cuánto o cómo expresar esta serie
geométrica verdad esto es lo mismo que
3x cuadradas simplemente estoy copiando
esto dividido entre 1 - la razón verdad
1 - las razones 1 - menos x al cubo que
es más x al cubo y esto será exactamente
igual déjeme seleccionar y copiar para
no volver a hacerlo
a copiar y pegar y ahí lo tienen tenemos
esta igualdad de ahí tenemos esta
igualdad muy bien entonces ahora lo que
quiero que pienses es en lo siguiente si
te fijas muy bien del lado izquierdo lo
que tenemos es que se parece como una
derivada de una función verdad de hecho
es parecido a la derivada de un
logaritmo de hecho va a ser la derivada
del logaritmo natural de uno más x al
cubo verdad bueno si no lo ves aún lo
que sí es cierto es que quizás esto es
una función que tiene una anti derivada
y tenemos aquí del lado derecho su
expresión en serie si nosotros queremos
saber quién es la expresión en serie de
la anti derivada de esta función
bastaría con integrar de ambos lados
verdad encontramos la anti derivada del
lado izquierdo y tendremos la anti
derivada del lado derecho si también
integramos muy bien entonces nuestro
la diversión que vamos a tener ahorita
es ver si podemos expresar la anti
derivada de esta función en términos de
alguna serie muy bien así que cómo
resolveremos este problema si nosotros
hacemos o igual a 1 + x al cubo entonces
estamos pensando en un cambio de
variable para resolver la integral
tendremos que de v será igual a 3x
cuadrada de xy entonces podemos hacer
ahora este cambio de variable y resolver
la integral tenemos tendremos
por ejemplo aquí está de hecho aquí se
ve verdad 3x cuadrada de x es nuestra de
eeuu que se encuentra justo aquí
entonces podemos utilizar el cambio de
variable y que tendremos la integral de
luego con el mismo color la integral de
1 / v
y esto lo voy a dejar con el color rojo
1 / v por dv
es igual a la integral que tenemos del
lado derecho ahorita vemos qué pasa con
la integral del lado derecho pero este
integral es el logaritmo natural esto es
el logaritmo natural del valor absoluto
de eeuu más cierta constante una
constante una primera constante del otro
lado va a salir otra pero ahorita
chequemos que es lo que va a ocurrir y
esto es exactamente igual al logaritmo
natural de eeuu que dijimos que era uno
más x al cubo y recuerden que hay que
ponerle un valor absoluto pero de hecho
de hecho no es necesario ponerle el
valor absoluto ya que la equis está
entre menos uno y uno si x está entre
menos uno y uno x al cubo vuelve a estar
entre menos uno y uno y si le sumamos
uno estará entre cero
y me parece que dos verdades exactamente
está entre 0 y 2 lo cual nos dice que
estoy adentro es no negativo así que de
hecho es positivo así que esto es el
logaritmo natural de 1 + x al cubo y ya
no es necesario ponerle el valor
absoluto y sumamos una constante de 1
ahora qué pasa del lado derecho qué pasa
si integramos esta serie sobre el
intervalo de convergencia por supuesto
entonces tendremos primero tendremos
alguna constante no sabemos cuál y vamos
a ir integrando paso por paso por
ejemplo aquí qué pasa si integramos 3x
cuadrada esto será tres veces la
integral de x cuadrada y la integral de
x cuadrada es x al cubo entre 3 pero
multiplicado por este 3
simplemente nos da x al cubo muy bien
vamos a ver qué ocurre con esta de aquí
ahora tendremos son menos tres veces la
integral de quizá la 5 que es x a las 6
sobre
6 y x este 3 nos queda x a las 6
dividido entre 2 muy bien vamos a ver
qué pasa con el siguiente si integramos
x a la 8 nos queda x a la 9 entre 9 pero
multiplicado por 3 nos queda x a la x a
la nueve exactamente sobre 3 muy bien y
sólo vamos a hacer el último por
diversión si integramos esto integramos
x a la 11 nos queda x a la 12 sobre 12
que multiplicado por 3 nos da x a la 12
sobre sobre sobre sobre 4 por supuesto 3
entre 12 es un cuarto muy bien y así
seguimos sumando así que ya tenemos una
expresión en serie para el logaritmo
natural de 1 más x al cubo por ejemplo
si pasamos restando este ese 1 lo que
nos va a quedar es
lo que nos va a quedar es lo siguiente
tenemos
esto esto implica que el logaritmo
natural de 1 + x al cubo es igual a c 2
- c 1 que a final de cuentas es
diferencia de constantes así que pues
solo es alguna constante más x al cubo
- x a las 6 entre 2
x a la 9 sobre 3 - x a la 12 entre 4 y
tú ya ves el patrón verdad espero que ya
ya distingas cuál es el patrón aquí y
que fue bueno aquí ya lo que obtuvimos
es una expresión para el logaritmo
natural de 1 + x al cubo una expresión
en serie sobre el intervalo de
convergencia que teníamos aquí así que
en resumen que fue lo que hicimos
teníamos una serie una serie que vimos
que se podía se podía expresar como una
serie geométrica esencialmente x 3x
cuadrada eso nos da una expresión para
esta serie que era 3 x cuadrada entre 1
+ x al cubo y tenía su expresión en
serie ahora bien si integramos de ambos
lados obtenemos una anti derivada de
esta función por un lado y que es el
logaritmo natural de uno más x al cubo y
del otro lado obtenemos una serie esto
me está diciendo que esta serie es una
expresión para esta función muy bien
ahora
quién es esta constante que obtuvimos
realmente necesitamos un poco más
información por ejemplo qué pasa si la
equis vale cero cuando la equis vale
cero tendremos el logaritmo natural de
uno que es igual a c
se más si x vale 0 aquí tendremos 0 si x
vale 0 tendremos menos 0 y así
sucesivamente verdad solo sumamos o
restamos ceros
así que nuestra constante es el
logaritmo natural de 1 pero nosotros
sabemos cuánto vale el logaritmo natural
de 1 y eso es 0 así que esta constante
no es otra cosa más que un 0 y ahora si
tenemos la expresión la expresión
correcta para el logaritmo natural de 1
más x al cubo en serie de potencias muy
bien esta es una expresión en serie de
potencias del logaritmo natural de 1 + x
al cubo muy bien de hecho déjenme nada
más concluir con la expresión de esta
serie en notación usando la letra griega
sigma verdad entonces tenemos logaritmo
natural de 1 + x al cubo va a ser igual
que la suma
con la serie desde n igual a uno hasta
infinito y que es lo que tenemos tenemos
x al cubo elevado a la nba
aquí sería x al cubo a la 1 x al cubo a
la 2 x al cubo a la 3 y así
sucesivamente divididos entre n verdad
aquí sería elevado a la 1 dividido entre
1 elevado a la 2 dividido entre 2
elevado a la 3 dividido entre 3 y me
falta ir intercambiando los signos así
que me falta por menos 1 y pensemos debe
ser un signo más en las x en la primera
posición signo menos en la segunda signo
más en la tercera es decir son signos
más en los impares y signos menos en los
pares así que esto simplemente se puede
escribir como menos 1 a la n 1 muy bien
entonces
así está correcto muy bien y ahí lo
tienen no sé ustedes pero yo lo
encuentro este resultado muy
satisfactorio la verdad es que me
pareció un ejercicio muy interesante